Speaker 1: Welcome back to The David Pakman Show,
I am Jesse Moore, and before we get started,
I just wanted to say thank you before
I lose my chance and I'm not back here
again until possibly David goes back on vacation
and possibly maybe asked me to substitute again.
I really have enjoyed doing this and I've enjoyed
some of the interaction. I've have the audience.
I don't read a lot of YouTube comments because
it's YouTube, but I just wanted to say thank you.
And if I am a flavor that you enjoy, I know I'm
not David. I'm not really anything like David.
But if if you enjoy what I do, I would encourage
you to find me on social media, find me on YouTube
and subscribe. Follow me. Interact in a way.
Thank you, guys. A little bit of good news here
related to the Supreme Court. Some rare, scant
news that is positive coming out of our six three
conservative Supreme Court. And that is the
fact that Amy CONI Barrett actually, shockingly,
has rejected a a hearing and which solidifies
a lower court ruling about Marzook mandates and
vaccines at the collegiate level. Reading from
the NBC headline Supreme Court Rejects Challenge
to Indiana University's vaccination requirement.
Eight students asked the court for an emergency
order, arguing the risks of vaccination outweigh
potential benefits to those in their age group.
Nonsense on its face and because of legal
precedent, this isn't like her charity, they
really have no they have no other recourse but to
do what Amy CONI Barrett did. The Supreme Court
refused on Thursday to block Indiana University's
requirement that students receive a covid vaccine
to attend classes in the in the fall semester.
It was the first legal test of a vaccine mandate
to come before the justices. A challenge to
the policy was directed to Amy CONI Barrett,
the justice in charge of that region of
the country who denied it. There were no
noted dissents from other justices. Look. It is a
nonsense political culture war B.S. argument that
Republicans are entering into for generations, for
instance, to immigrate to this country, you must
have a slate of vaccines. When I went to boot
camp for the United States Marine Corps, there
were all kinds of vaccines that I was required to
undertake because I was joining the military. If
you go to college, my wife in undergrad and her
graduate degree had to have a slate of vaccines.
That's the same when I went to school. Elementary
school, there are inoculations that are required.
This is a nonsense Norns starting argument that
is only fueled by Republican culture war B.S..
Eight Indiana students asked the court for an
emergency order, arguing that the risks associated
with the vaccine outweighed the potential benefits
to the population in their age group, quote,
protection of others does not relieve our society
from the central canon of medical ethics requiring
voluntary and informed consent, end quote, they
told the justices seeking an emergency order
to block the vaccine requirement. A federal judge
ruled last month that the school had the right to
pursue a, quote, reasonable and due process
of vaccination in the legitimate interest of
public health for its students, faculty and staff.
The students have many options, the judge said,
such as applying for an exemption, taking the
semester off, viewing classes online or attending
another university entirely. Yogurt options,
snowflakes. Pull yourself up by your bootstraps
and make a decision. The Seventh US Circuit
Court of Appeals, based in Chicago, agreed,
it noted that the Supreme Court ruled in nineteen
oh five. There's precedent for this again,
the Supreme Court ruled in 1995 that a
state can require all members of the public
to be vaccinated against smallpox. Indiana's
requirement is less demanding, the court said,
allowing exemptions for students who object on the
basis of medical conditions or religious beliefs.
An argument can be made that those are appropriate
exemptions, certainly a medical getting
relief based on a medical condition
if you have an actual medical condition.
Certainly if you're immunocompromised, you're
afflicted with a myriad of other conditions
that possibly would qualify you for that.
Religion, it's a little slippery, slippery, a
slippery slope, then medical, I believe, because
anybody can make up anything
and say it's their religion.
So. That's where we are and there are a series
of other cases that are rolling their way through
some even here universities in California that
are likely going to meet this same exact fate.